good evening the first award of the
evening is for best supporting actor
i know that the longer i'm up here and
the longer i speak
the more they will wait
and the more they will suffer
so
so let's do it here are the nominees for
best performance by an actor in a
supporting role
matt damon in invictus
woody harrelson in the messenger
christopher plummer in the last station
stanley tucci in the lovely bones
christophe vaults in inglorious bastards
and the winner is
christophe wolves an inglorious bastard
this is the first academy award and
nomination for kristoff vaults
oscar and penelope that's an uber bingo
i i always
i always wanted to discover some
new continent and i thought i had to go
this way
and then i was introduced
to quentin tarantino
who was putting together an expedition
that was equipped by harvey weinstein
and lauren spender and david lindy and
he put this script in front of me and he
said this is where we're going but we're
going the other way
so brad pitt helped me on board and
diane kruger was there and melanie
lauren and dunimi menu she and bob
riches and sally menken and
adam schweitzer and lisa castella and
everybody helped me find a place
universal and the weinstein company and
icm and quentin
with his with his unorthodox
methods of navigation this
um fearless explorer took this ship
across and brought it in with flying
colors
and that's why i'm here
and this is your welcoming embrace and
there's no way i can ever thank you
enough but i can start right now thank
you
you